we are live at a press conference here
in Chicago Illinois where we hear that
any minute the Nostalgia Critic is going
to make a public appearance addressing
his last video for those who are unaware
the Nostalgia Critic posted a let's play
of Bart's nightmare last week which was
considered by many to be so horrendously
unfunny that they'd rather shove a
needle Factory up their scrotums ah and
here is the nostalgia critic preparing
to explain his actions they allowed me a
short amount of time out the internet
State Penitentiary a little surprised to
see that place actually existed so they
allowed me a short time out to answer
your questions
addressing the video I did last week yes
how does it feel to know that you've
made the absolute worst let's play to
ever be put on the Internet bad
definitely bad but hopefully I can make
some more funny videos and move on from
it yes I got a robber break into my
house kill my wife and eat my children
he's not as bad as you thank you yes
Melvin the father of the Joker emo Jones
this recent let's play Nazi Germany that
is all if we could keep the questions to
actual questions how do you Travis tea
among the world look when everything is
said and done at the end of the day I
just made a bad video oh you're better
mister Magritte ik sure you try
something new it didn't work
but now you deserve to give your fans
something better hey mean I'd like those
degrees to do if it's up at night but
you oh yeah fans I think better well
I'll tell you what I'll tell you what
why don't I do a positive review of a
movie that a lot of people seem to enjoy
oh you mean like jeans in the Jane Peach
teens and the Giant Peach cinematic
brilliance oh yes how can I not forget
the awkwardly written yet structurally
confusing masterpiece that is James and
the Giant Peach not that there's
anything wrong with that it's not like
the film did poorly at the box office
but got a surprising call following over
the years where that the critical
reaction at the time was lukewarm at
best but recently is being declared it's
a timeless classic it's not like my need
to please the masses is going to affect
my opinion in any conceivable way I'm
just gonna praise it for the wonderful
family robbed that it is really so for
those who don't know the film is based
on the book by Willy Wonka author Roald
Dahl and directed by famous stop-motion
director Henry Stone who also directed
The Nightmare Before Christmas
so you can see his stop-motion has
clearly gotten better
good god they look like actual
people look it's like a camel and
Neville over there looks like a train
engine and that one looks like a crappy
CGI effect I mean a good CGI effect and
can you say the tallest building in the
world
[Music]
that's where we're going
perfect I mean they formed the Empire
State Building just as they tell up
they're about to go to the Empire State
Building
it's the clouds in my neighborhood were
that convenient
they finally there's a way I could avoid
the Chicago traffic the l-train of
course that's a great idea
oh but which one goes to the loop of
course how stupid of me but what if I
want to keep my options open
wow that's amazingly helpful thanks
incredibly convenient passing pile of
clouds so everything seems to be
absolutely peachy for James and his
angelic parents but then things suddenly
and I do mean suddenly go very run then
one day a terrible thing happened
an angry rhinoceros appeared out of
nowhere
and gobbled up his poor mother and
father an angry rhinoceros appeared out
of nowhere and gobbled up his poor
mother and father I mean really what
else can you say but what that is the
most have no work explanation of parents
disappearing ever they don't explain it
we never see it happen just don't worry
not sir it comes out of nowhere it eats
them
that's all over in 35 seconds plan yeah
I'm not editing that down either that's
literally how they show it to us parents
there's dawn blame the right that's a
pretty rushed explanation isn't it can
you imagine if one of the Disney movies
did that
look simple everything the light touches
is our kingdom and then the Rhino a
tomorrow probably better so of course
now he has to live with his evil ants
yeah how come the kindest parents in the
world always have the most big-ass
relatives Nonie gagging in dreamland
when there's so much weeds to pull wood
okay I think this calls for another wood
Jesus Christ whenever we use that
picture for their email greetings Happy
New Year from the high existence may all
your resolutions come true and don't
forget to so this is aunt sponge and
aunt Spiker you know when you name your
kids that are you just begging for them
to turn out like this they're played by
British comedians Joanna Lumley and
Miriam Margolis and in keeping with
England tradition they give the best
British confidence build-up they can
muster you never even saw that Rhino
coming that Rider and the Beast will get
you to know in any other movie I'd say
these two were strongly constructed as a
bomb shelter made out of popsicle sticks
but in this movie it works because I
really want you to like me right now so
as James gets back to work what what
what watch he can't help but hum a merry
little too
[Music]
Wow what horrible lyrics what a plan to
with totally forgettable melody this can
only be the work of that's right Randy
Newman wrote these songs
oh and just like his other work it's
lame annoying repetitive unoriginal
inspiring charming wonderful piece of
music that I expect from such a musical
genius I mean how can you not love such
emotionally packed lyrics like my name
is James that's what mother calls me my
name is James so it's always been down
since gee nice inside isn't it I mean
here I thought James as in James and the
Giant Peach
what's referring to somebody else no
this song points out that it's the James
right in front of us and not a James in
another town or country and the fact
that he explains it's his mother that
named him is also very important because
we could have made the horrible mistake
of thinking his father negative but no
it's incredibly crucial lyric points out
that it was in fact his mother oh I
wonder what other incredible insights
are going to give us
[Music]
well that obviously explains itself I
don't have to explain it for you
so this James is admiring what a
beautiful set out it is today he
suddenly comes across the lake Pete
Postlethwaite playing what looks like a
time-traveling Captain Crunch
don't be frightened James I mean you
know how how do you know my name
I know more than just your name I know
your pen size to just let me have that
so he gives him a bag of Kryptonite
pasta that he claims can make all his
dreams come true what are they exactly
1,000 long slimy crocodile tongues
boiled in the skull of a dead witch for
20 days and 20 nights and the fingers of
a young monkey the gizzard of a paid the
beak of a parrot and three spoonfuls of
sugar and a peeled large in a pear tree
the only downside is he trips and lets
it fly all over the place
[Music]
the to inter angry of course because
that's the one don't they've been given
when they come across an amazing
discovery look on that branch why that
old trees never had so much as a blossom
on it let alone him well I'll be blowed
up a peach apparently has the power to
keep on growing until it finally
transforms into Garfield's anus the ants
of course seize the opportunity to make
a buck off of this and start charging
money for people to see it it's like
someone put clown makeup on the
Cryptkeeper
and don't even think of getting near our
peach so well James is out doing what
else what what he comes across one last
piece of nuclear snot that allows him to
climb inside the peach and apparently
change his appearance so it turns out
the glowing turtle semen made a bunch of
the bugs bigger and able to talk and it
turns out that they all coincidentally
want to go to New York but they have to
hurry fast or else the two evil odds
will come across them
[Music]
I don't really like playing that Rhino
cart don't they but something that was
vaguely explained in a millisecond they
sure feel swing it up a lot okay great
the movie suddenly turned into Marble
Madness
[Music]
so the peach rolls out to the Atlantic
Ocean where it appears all they have to
do is write it all the way to New York
City I'll get us there sure I sailed all
the five seas but they have to look out
for a giant mechanical shark ship oh
don't act like you've never seen one
floats to the surface and tries to catch
them we do our hunting atomic but James
thinks up a pretty creative idea by
grouping all the seagulls he can find
and using them to fly away and if you're
wondering where that giant harpooning
metal shark came from or what his story
was so as they start eating part of the
peach because they're hungry all the
bugs decide to meet in many strange and
scrumptious dishes in my time really
we're singing a song about eating the
goddamn peach these foods are beyond
comparison I have a problem with them
singing about this at all I'm sure this
does a great deal to further the story
and give insight into the characters I'm
just a little curious what other similar
musical numbers they turn down to fit
this one in such important songs like
the sky is blue my tongue is in my mouth
let's make Pooh and God knows what else
God can you imagine what this movie
would be like without these essential
Randy Newman songs no but gommage I do
so as the spider starts to tuck James to
sleep or is she planning to eat him he
flunks out that she much prefers a life
of being alone I think it's much nicer
to Wednesday I would not know
- yes honey if he didn't know it isn't
that nature - a fear of me miss I cannot
change well wait when in any of the
previous scenes did it indicate that
they were afraid of her or that she kept
her distance or hell even that she was
quiet she interacts with them dances
with them she can think the morandi
thorns so where's the sudden loner story
are coming from that away if I am
sucking your brains out in the middle of
the night I apologize
so James goes to sleep and has a dream
that he's in Monty Python's Flying
Circus
[Music]
now of course that scene was necessary
because it needed to show that James is
afraid of a giant rhinoceros that killed
his parents see I'm glad that they had
this scene in the movie because I never
would have put together that James was
afraid of a giant rhinoceros at
countless nights heck I'm surprised
Randy Nolan didn't write a song about
that I know little boy fascinating
parents don't bring a much Joyce and
Randy but it turns out the centipede led
them in the wrong direction and now
they're in the Antarctic so they go
underwater to see if they can find a
compass to lead them in the right
direction they come across several
pirate ships including one that has the
statues of his aunts in front of it I
don't get it
when they suddenly come across skeleton
pirates one of them played by Jack
Skellington was this an incredibly
clever cameo Horwitz Henry Selick just
too cheap to make other puppets either
way it's pretty cool now to me what you
know about Christmas land but James and
the spider come to save him just making
of the law of underwater physics as they
go and manage to get the compass
[Music]
mr. centipede would you please do us the
honor of navigating us out of this
icebox seeing how you got us into this
icebox so just as you're wondering if
those birds ever need to eat or sleep we
see genes come across a rather touching
musical moment
[Music]
No well that's nice that's a very
genuine moment that's an enchanted
musical scene that doesn't need to
succumb to the typical Randy Newman for
you a little time just look at where we
are
[Music]
no don't dance with her it is in your
nature to have fear of her
[Music]
by the way if you're wondering with all
of those things flying around in the
background our kiss what never explained
but that's not a bad thing no it makes
about as much sense Asst oh I don't know
an unexplained giant rhinoceros killing
some middle-aged people but that works
in a way I can't possibly explain at all
it still works it still works so just
what it looks like they finally made it
to their destination they come across a
rather unfriendly visitor
[Music]
look out a rhino
so the Rhino zips the birds allowing the
peach to fall
I knew the boy actually it lands on top
of the Empire State Building right dab
in the middle of New York and just what
exactly was that giant Rhino that James
said was only a bunch of smoke and noise
I don't know I don't know all that
build-up and they never explained what
he was running from that halt I see us
so after James changes back to his
normal self the ants come in and tried
to take back what they claim is
rightfully theirs but James isn't gonna
have any of it it's so something he
dreamed up well maybe it started that
way as a dream but doesn't everything
those buildings these lights this whole
city
maybe that's what I did I came to man up
coming here but then I did it you're
going home I made it I'm not the one
who's nothing you are
[Applause]
you speak to us this way peachy but it
turns out the buds come in to save the
day the city can't believe their eyes so
they pull the two ants up and wrap them
up in wet no Doubt's suffocating them to
death I look at the police officer all
this time it's like yeah so everybody
brings out the confetti they've been
holding on to for god knows what reason
and James becomes a hero telling all the
kids on the block his tale and then an
exciting unexplained anticlimax with a
rhino chorus 2 penis but if I was to
find some fault with it just hear me out
I would say that while the film is
creative it's also pretty clumsy a lot
of stuff doesn't add up a lot of scenes
go nowhere the songs are pretty
forgettable and the live-action stuff is
surprisingly more over the top than the
animated stuff what they change them the
book actually raises more questions that
does simplify things which results in it
being both weird and confusing but with
that say the animation is very good
designs are a lot of fun even things
like those cheesy sets actually do have
sort of a strange charm to them you also
have to give the film credit that didn't
need to resort to pop cultural
references as a lot of animated films
were doing at that time
it was at least trying to tell a
timeless story so is it for me no but I
can see why it has an audience the stuff
that's neat is still pretty neat and
there's a lot of things in the movie
that can be considered pretty impressive
so I guess I can't really fault people
for enjoying something that does give
way to a lot of imaginative scenarios it
may be flawed but I think we all know
that you're gonna get a great big dose
of something really creative then that's
all I gotta say about that there have I
restored anything in your guys's eyes he
says he didn't like the movie Kuro um
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's always
sometimes I
[Music]
what-what-what-what black